it's true harry has talked to his
brother and he has talked to his father
too
cbs this morning anchor gail king who is
also a close friend to oprah winfrey
and attended meghan markle's baby shower
when she was pregnant with archie
opened up on the morning news program
tuesday about the conversation she says
she had with prince harry and megan
following their tell-all interview with
oprah that aired earlier this month
i'm not trying to break news but i did
actually call them to see how they were
feeling
willian is is devastated by this
interview don't forget the duchess of
cambridge has been dragged into this
whole saga and william will will hate
that
um and of course relationship between
father and son
is now at an all-time low during the
90-minute special with oprah
harry talked about his older brother
prince william and his dad prince
charles and said at one point his dad
stopped speaking to him amid his
decision to step
down as a senior member of the royal
family and in the wake of the explosive
oprah interview
gail says she's learned that harry has
spoken with his dad
and brother the word i was given was
that the
those conversations were not productive
but they are glad
that they have at least started a
conversation the talk at the palace is
that they are
absolutely horrified by what has been
said they feel that
harry has literally thrown the family
under a bus
gail adds that harry and megan are still
upset with buckingham palace
noting there are quote false stories
that are quote disparaging against megan
that are still coming out in the days
following the interview
no one is in the royal family has talked
to megan yet
at this particular time and i think it's
frustrating for them to see that it's a
racial conversation about the royal
family when
all they wanted all along was for the
royals to intervene and tell the press
to stop with the unfair
uh inaccurate false stories that
definitely have a racial slant and until
you can acknowledge that
i think it's going to be hard to move
forward but they both want to move
forward with this
and they both want you know they want
healing in this family at the end of the
day that is harry's family
while they were graced for for something
explosive they totally underestimated
just how far harry and megan would go
and i think they took everyone by
surprise
as for gail she went on to praise the
duchess of sussex
who is currently facing allegations of
bullying former royal aides
anyone who's worked with her will tell
you exactly who she is you know she's
really a very sweet caring person and as
i say megan has documents to back up
everything that she said
on oprah's interview the times newspaper
has reported that the duchess allegedly
bullied
two members of her household staff out
of kensington palace and made the life
of the third member of staff
almost unbearable those are the
allegations they are strongly refuted
by the duchess of sussex who says she
didn't bully anyone
out of the palace last week prince
william broke his silence following
megan and harry's interview
in which megan claimed that prior to
giving birth to archie
one of the royal family members
expressed concern about the potential
color of his skin
sir have you broke have you spoken to
your brother since the interview
i haven't spoken yet but i will do and
can you just let me know is that the
royal family a racist family sir
i'm very much not a racist any healing
is going to take a very long time and i
think what feels
so sad is that he was just getting
family relations back on track